bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo dédiée aux
gardiens de la galaxie 3 je pensais à la
base vous proposer une analyse de
trailer vu que une bande annonce sur le
film vient de sortir là tout récemment
mais je me dis que ce serait plus
intéressant pourquoi pas qu'on essaye
déjà de faire des des théories que je
vous partage ma vision comme ça on fait
le point sur les gardiens tout ça enfin
bref quoi on essaie d'être complet quoi
donc sur ce ne tardons pas il y a plein
de choses à dire en plus les gardiens on
en a pas tant que ça parlé sur la chaîne
donc va falloir rattraper ça n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner et puis bah écoutez
bah on y va premièrement où nous en
sommes avec les gardiens de la galaxie
en réalité l'équipe n'a pas vraiment
avancé depuis les gardiens 2 et Avengers
endgame nous avons quand même eu
quelques informations de par certains
films comme Thor 4 ou le spécial Noël
mais cela nous permet juste d'avoir la
situation de base pour le troisième film
Les Gardiens de la galaxie sont
désormais établis sur nowhere la fameuse
tête de Céleste coupée qui était occupée
par le collectionneur ces derniers ont
été rejoints par Cosmo qui s'occupe de
la sécurité de la base mais également
craquelin depuis les gardiens 2 qui
intervient désormais de temps en temps
dans les aventures de l'équipe comme on
a pu le voir dans Thor love and thunder
déjà rien que ça c'est quand même plutôt
intéressant car cela nous permet de
souligner un point concernant les
gardiens c'est qu'ils sont désormais
reconnus et sans trop dans l'univers à
l'instar des gardiens 1 et 2 où ils
étaient plus des vagabonds ils sont
aujourd'hui un véritable groupe confirmé
avec des gens derrière eux de vrais
défenseurs de la veuve et de l'orphelin
dans l'espace et justement en parlant de
ça depuis les événements d'Avengers
Infinity War et endgame les gardiens
semblent retourner à leur fonction
principal de protecteur de l'espace
comment témoignent Thor love and sender
et c'est quelque chose qui je trouve
mérite également d'être souligné car
depuis endgame les gardiens semblent un
peu la tête dans le guidon dans le sens
où on dirait qu'ils ont laissé de côté
leurs problèmes ou autres quêtes
personnelles alors je ne dis pas ça par
hasard car je pense justement que la
réalité va rattraper les gardiens dans
leur troisième film prenons par exemple
bien évidemment le cas de gamora Queen à
la fin den game à peine le combat contre
Thanos terminé était déjà à la recherche
de gamora pourtant comme la démontré les
récentes production cela ne semble plus
trop d'actualité ces limites comme si
c'était une quête secondaire quill n'a
jamais retrouvé la trace de gamora et il
est revenu à ce qu'il savait faire de
mieux être un gardien de la galaxie
d'ailleurs tout cet aspect personnel est
de réalité qui rattrape nos héros je
pense que cela ne va pas s'arrêter à
Queen roquette mérite d'être souligné
aussi mais chaque chose en son temps
faisons tout d'abord le point sur Queen
et gamora où on en est la concernant si
je vous propose de faire un point sur
gamora c'est parce qu'en vrai ça fait
quand même un moment qu'on ne l'a pas vu
et je pense du coup que certains ou
certaines peuvent être un peu perdus par
rapport à cette situation pour faire
bref notre gamora a été tué de la main
de Thanos pour récupérer la pierre de
l'âme sur vormir pendant les événements
d'Infinity war la gamora que l'on
connaît est morte et fin de l'histoire
sauf que pendant leur casse temporel les
Avengers sont envoyés Nebula récupéré la
pierre du pouvoir en 2014 et
malheureusement cette dernière a subi
une sorte d'interférence avec la Nébula
du passé celle de 2014 et du coup cela a
révélé le plan des Avengers de voyager
dans le temps pour récupérer les pierres
de cette période par conséquent Thanos a
pu voyager dans le futur pour atteindre
notre époque et la gamora du passé qui
accompagnait son père a été ramené au
passage nous avons donc actuellement une
gamora qui se balade qui n'a jamais
connu sa période en tant que gardienne
de la galaxie ou encore sa romance avec
Will etc etc est-ce que c'est clair pour
vous maintenant si nous retournons sur
le film des gardiens 3 bon déjà il est
clair que gamora n'a jamais été ramené
avant car faciliter scénaristique toi
même tu connais attendons le troisième
film pour ça cependant la question que
je trouve intéressante c'est comment et
pourquoi gamora retrouverait les
gardiens de la galaxie car techniquement
comme démontré dans endgame elle n'en a
rien à faire faut tout rebâtir
concernant sa relation avec les autres
membres et bien je pense que nous
devrions nous tourner vers un autre
personnage présent dans le troisième
film des gardiens et qui va permettre
pourquoi pas la réunion de tout le monde
ça y est nous y sommes après six ans de
teasing Adam Warlock apparaît enfin à
l'écran et
inutile de vous dire à quel point je
pense que le personnage sera clé dans ce
troisième film et surtout qu'il aura un
immense avenir dans l'univers des films
Marvel en fait ce qui est intéressant
par rapport à Adam Warlock concernant
gamora c'est que rappelez-vous suite au
vol des batteries à nul axes par Rocket
la grande prêtresse Ayesha de sovren est
très en colère après l'équipe et pour
mener à bien sa vengeance elle va donner
naissance à Adam pour traquer les
gardiens sauf que coûte théâtre La
gamora que nous connaissions faisait
partie des gardiens au moment du vol
mais depuis cette dernière est décédée
et nous avons désormais la gamora du
passé néanmoins Ayesha et Adam ne le
savent pas ça du coup c'est là que le
quiproquo devrait s'installer c'est
potentiellement pour moi pour moi à ce
qui va réunir nos protagonistes le fait
que Adam soit l'ennemi commun agamora et
au gardien car on ne va pas se mentir
que le maître de l'évolution bah agamora
elle s'en fout elle n'a rien à voir avec
lui donc voilà et dans une autre mesure
mais je ne peux me baser sur rien bien
évidemment mais je me dis que pourquoi
pas Adam aurait pourquoi pas capturé
gamora de son côté et tout ça et que par
la suite ce soit autour des gardiens et
que cela soit la chose qui permet
justement que tout le monde soit réuni
en gros quoi dans tous les cas comme le
traduit le trailer il semblerait qu'à
terme gamora revienne dans l'équipe
après avoir si elle resterait plus que
le temps d'un seul film mais la scène où
les gardiens semblent en prison rappelle
étrangement la scène du premier film où
les gardiens arrêtés ont finalement fait
connaissance et ont commencé à
collaborer ensemble
continuons maintenant sur le cas de
roquette à roquette je vous vois déjà
venir ouais je pense qu'il va mourir
ouais là c'est très dangereux pour
Rocket et en vrai on ne va pas se mentir
je suis plutôt d'accord avec ça mais bon
il y a quand même des choses
intéressantes à dire sur Rocket pour ce
troisième film bon déjà il est
nécessaire de le rappeler mais ce
troisième film des gardiens de la
galaxie et le dernier film où nous
allons avoir la team des gardiens tels
que nous la connaissons actuellement ce
qui veut dire qu'après ce film nous
sommes censés avoir un changement
drastique sur l'équipe de base que nous
suivons alors cela ne veut pas forcément
dire que tout le monde va mourir
regardez endgame Steve a juste pris sa
retraite dans le passé par exemple il se
peut qu'il y ait des séparations à la
fin du film et non seulement des morts
mais voilà tout ça pour dire que
l'équipe des gardiens va changer
personnellement je vais vous dire ma
perception mais je pense que les plus à
craindre
effectivement requête mais également
Drax Drax on a déjà pas mal exploré son
passé dans le premier film et le
personnage commence petit à petit à
s'essoufflé en vrai après moi je
pencherai pourquoi pas pour une
séparation concernant Nebula et gamora
il y a moyen de proposer du sang neuf
mais revenons là dessus un peu plus tard
il faut d'abord que nous parlions de
Rocket effectivement je pense que Rocket
va sûrement mourir dans le troisième
film des gardiens le trailer fait
d'ailleurs tout pour nous inquiéter le
concernant surtout qu'en plus on va
explorer son passé avec le maître de
l'évolution mais voilà j'ai une théorie
à vous proposer le concernant je pense
que le sujet de la mort de Rocket va
arriver très vite dans le troisième film
des gardiens peut-être même dès
l'introduction mais pourquoi cela et
bien justement tournons-nous vers les
comics en fait Rocket possède une
condition très particulière comme vous
le savez les films en avaient déjà parlé
mais Rocket est un personnage qui a été
génétiquement et cybernétiquement
modifié il est ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
à cause de Lourdes d'expérience qu'ils
l'ont transformé sauf que ce qu'on nous
dit pas dans les films et avoir s'il le
feront dans le troisième opus mais le
lourd traitement qu'a subi requête n'est
pas sans conséquence pour faire simple
le personnage est censé se dégrader au
bout d'un moment c'est quelque chose
qu'il ne peut esquiver son corps va à
terme rejeter les expériences qu'il a
subi cela commence avec des maux de tête
la perte de sa fourrure puis à terme
requête va nous quitter et c'est là que
c'est intéressant car en fait dans les
comics quand Rocket va comprendre qu'il
est en train de se dégrader son
comportement va totalement changer le
personnage ne voudra pas que ses
coéquipiers le voient à mocher donc il
va s'isoler et quitter l'équipe et en
plus de cela sachant ces jours-contés il
va vouloir régler les dettes qu'il a
toujours mise de côté il va rendre les
objets qu'il a volé etc etc et tout ça
là je me dis que ce serait très
pertinent pour le film pourquoi et bien
tout simplement car nous savons qu'il
sera un temps soit peu centré sur Rocket
et son passé dans plusieurs plans du
trailer nous voyons que Rocket n'est pas
dans l'équipe des gardiens ceux qui
traduit son potentiel isolement mais en
plus de cela nous avons Lila qui est le
grand amour de Rocket dans les comics ou
encore le maître de l'évolution qui est
très certainement réécrit dans le MCU
pour être le créateur de Rocket donc des
éléments du passé du personnage qu'il
aimerait régler avant de mourir je ne
sais pas pourquoi mais je le vois gros
comme une maison le film commence Rocket
comprend que ces jours sont comptés ils
s'isole et se rappelle de son passé
pourquoi pas il se rappellerait de lilas
son grand amour laissait derrière lui et
du coup cela tout le monde à faire face
au maître de l'évolution vous voyez
l'idée mais du coup est-ce que cela veut
dire que Rocket va forcément mourir à la
fin du film est-ce qu'il ne peut pas
être sauvé et bien je vous avoue qu'une
autre théorie se profile par rapport à
ça et pour cela il va falloir se
concentrer sur une intrigue très
spéciale du troisième film c'est le cas
de Adam Warlock et du maître de
l'évolution vous voyez le moment où les
gardiens atterrissent sur une drôle de
terre mais où les gens ont tous des
têtes d'animaux et bien pour celles et
ceux qui ne savent pas les gardiens vont
atterrir pendant leur périple sur la
contre terre en fait le
high-évolutionary ou maître de
l'évolution et comme son nom l'indique
un savant fou de l'évolution c'est un
expert de la génétique et très souvent
il rend justement des animaux
anthropomorphes et en gros dans les
comics il sait servi d'un morceau de
planète pour bâtir une copie conforme de
la terre et là bas c'est en fait son
terrain de jeu ou ses expériences vivent
dans la pseudo harmonie et où le mal
n'existe pas pareil le moment où les
gardiens sont sapés en eux-mêmes gus il
semble parcourir une des créations du
maître de l'évolution et le moment où
ils sont en prison également mais bref
tout ça c'est pour votre culture car ce
qui nous intéresse surtout cela va être
Adam Warlock
je suis très curieux de voir ce qu'ils
vont nous proposer dans le troisième
film car en réalité dans les comics le
moment où Adam Warlock va croiser le
chemin du maître de l'évolution c'est
vraiment un moment clé dans l'histoire
du personnage c'est comment je pourrais
dire ça une sorte de pivot voire même
une sorte de tremplin pour la faire
courte quand Adam a été créé il était
une entité nulle dans le sens où il est
sans raison dans l'espace il ne comprend
pas le social ou le bien et le mal c'est
une coquille vide en gros Adam n'a
jamais connu d'enfance d'aventure ou
autre interactions et cela pèse sur le
personnage à terme il retournera dans
son cocon et c'est à ce moment que c'est
intéressant car le maître de l'évolution
va le récupérer à partir de là la vie
d'Adam changera considérablement le high
évolutionnari voit en Adam un potentiel
énorme il a besoin d'un champion pour sa
contre terre car une menace se profile
dans son monde et par conséquent il va
modifier Adam et le faire évoluer il va
se servir de la gemme de l'âme pour le
grade et le baptisera de lui-même Adam
Warlock et c'est là que cela m'intrigue
car les gardiens 3 va réunir à la fois
Adam Warlock le maître de l'évolution et
la contre terre donc avoir si le maître
de l'évolution meurt à la fin du film
mais si ce n'est pas le cas Adam
pourrait être recueilli par ce dernier à
la fin ou du moins il se pourrait que
nous ayons une référence au comics si
Adam viendrait sauver entre guillemets
les habitants de la Contre-Terre des
gardiens de la galaxie qui sont en train
de l'envahir entre guillemets enfin bref
ce sont des idées comme ça mais en tout
cas je pense que Adam va drastiquement
évoluer pendant le film en fait vu que
c'est sa première véritable apparition
officielle dans un long métrage de
Marvel je pense qu'ils vont avant tout
nous le présenter et du coup pour cela
reprendre en gros la base du personnage
Ayesha a créé Adam dans un but de
vengeance sauf qu'on le sait les
gardiens ne sont pas des mauvaises
personnes et Adam va forcément s'en
rendre compte ou du moins sera résonné
par nos héros et je pense sincèrement
que nous ferons face aux problèmes
existentiels qui concerne Adam pourquoi
son existence or vengeance que faire
maintenant si la mission d'Ayesha est
terminée ou annuler nous allons avoir la
coquille vide en manque d'expérience et
bien évidemment je pense que comme dans
les comics Adam accompagnera les
gardiens possiblement par la suite car
effectivement Adam n'est pas un vrai
antagoniste c'est plutôt un héros voire
une entité neutre et ce dernier a
collaboré et fait partie de l'équipe des
gardiens de la galaxie dans les comics à
un moment donné et justement c'est là où
après toutes ces nous allons pouvoir
répondre à la question de la survie de
roquette en fait je me dis que pour
prouver au spectateur et au gardien
cADAM est un personnage de bonne foi et
bien l'entité va devoir se racheter de
la mission vengeance pour laquelle il a
été créé et envoyé je me dis que
pourquoi pas vu que le peuple de soverne
sont des experts de la génétique et de
l'évolution cela concerne aussi Adam et
du coup peut-être que Adam pourrait être
celui qui va sauver roquette à la fin du
film et soigner sa dégradation alors
c'est de la folle théorie mais imaginez
si Adam plaçait requête dans son cocon
pour le soigner c'est une idée de fou en
vrai mais bon voilà je m'emballe
peut-être un petit peu
[Musique]
écoutez je pense que nous allons nous
arrêter là en vrai je pense qu'après ce
film Marvel va pouvoir nous proposer des
variantes de l'équipe des gardiens par
exemple dans les comics Adam et gamora
ont beaucoup collaboré ils ont fait
partie et ils ont même conçu l'équipe
Infinity watch qui est une équipe en
gros de super-héros liés aux pierres de
l'infini et je me dis que pourquoi pas
Adam pourrait possiblement apporter un
second souffle à gamora et bah
accessoirement Nebula aussi il est sûr
en tout cas qu'Adam travaillera avec les
gardiens et à terme je pense vraiment
que le personnage va apporter beaucoup
de changements dans l'équipe mais voilà
comme je vous disais à voir s'il y aura
des séparations et non seulement des
morts il se pourrait que il y ait des
membres des gardiens de la galaxie qui
prennent leur retraite tout simplement
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
cette vidéo était déjà un premier jet de
théorie concernant les gardiens 3 et bah
écoutez j'espère que cela vous aura plu
en plus il y a plein de choses à dire
maintenant qu'il y a également les
éternels qui sont un peu dans cette vibe
de autre groupe qui circule dans
l'espace voilà il y a moyen de relier
avec les gardiens surtout qu'il y a
cette histoire de Céleste aussi bref si
la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner et à laisser un beau pouce bleu
et puis surtout bah à donner votre
perception vos idées vos théories en
commentaire concernant le film c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui m'intéresse
et j'adore vraiment lire vos
commentaires sur ce c'était Argo rock
que le lionhe soit avec vous allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]